so she did her phd uh
from the christian albert albrecht's uh
university
in keele sorry i graduated from
christian alberts university at keel and
did her phd from university of
leiden in the netherlands and
subsequently she became a professor at
auckland university
she works at the intersection of sad smt
solvers and computer algebra systems
and in 2015 she independently came up
with this
concept of combining sat solvers and
computer algebra systems
so without further ado erica please go
ahead
thank you thank you for the nice
introduction you can hear me
yes perfect it is so nice to see
young researchers at curtis being
fascinated from these beautiful problems
and finding elegant solutions
and indeed this combination of certain
cars is
offers very much possibilities for also
new ideas
so what i would like to show you today
is
also a new idea based on previous ideas
which we get when we try to combine
these systems
so i would like to talk about the
marriage of two words
and what nice things can come out and i
will
try to focus on the intuition i will not
go into details a little bit technically
it is but not much but let us start at
the beginning
so what we want to do is we want to
solve logical formulas
by essentially solving and
we look a bit into the solving
mechanisms of
smt solving and what we see is that
there are different modules in it
and these modules are combined but
they are not combined just putting them
aside like by curtis we also
have seen i would call it but the sats
over shows a kind of abstraction
but it is dedicated to the problem so
but in snt solving is beautiful and
impressive that
often putting together pieces results
in new methods
so propositional logic we know um
curtis used this also in the upper level
of his solving methods and what i will
focus on also is
real algebra and we know that this is of
course more complex
even representing satisfying assignments
is more complex
but computer algebra systems already
addressed
the problem of satisfiability checking
so i focus today on quantifier-free
formulas
but the boolean combination is still
challenging
and then i do not introduce smt solving
i
assume that most of you know but in
traditional smt surveying i would like
to emphasize again that
also there is satsova interacts with the
theory server
but they are they do not have equal
rights the sat solver is first
that site is called lazy sat modular
theories because the theory is evaluated
lazily so the sat solver goes ahead
and searches for solutions for the
boolean skeleton
for the boolean structure of the problem
and consults a serious server to check
consistency in the real domain
and now what kind of theory service can
be put in into this
theory-solving approach we know a lot of
decision procedures probably you are
experts
in some of them so the question
arises can we simply plug in these
procedures into smt solving
and the answer is well not directly
at least not directly in an efficient
way because
the satsova will incrementally search
for solutions and
in the less lazy solving it will
frequently ask the series server
for a set of constraints then for an
extended set of constraint
an extension of this and so on until a
solution
full solution is found or a conflict
is detected so this should work
incrementally
and if the theory is or or the
constraints in the theory
are inconsistent it should give an
explanation in form
of a tautology of a lemma and should be
able to backtrack
i will not go into these details how to
adapt these decision procedures but
this was the origin of my research and
of our smt servers because we said
where there are so many interesting
decision procedures
uh which are not yet efficiently
embeddable in smt solving so let us try
make them smt compliant
and on the way we detected a lot of
so some some extensions have been
straightforward but some
others are very interesting and with
interesting i mean
they could not only adapt these this
decision procedures
but we could even gain more insight into
the nature of the problems
and thereby also improve or change
modify
algorithms and find new ones
so first to our server before i will
give you an example
our software is called smt red real
algebraic
toolbox is red at its heart
there is a c plus plus library called
carl for real arithmetic computations
this can also
call external computer algebra systems
if they are installed a few
i do not go into these details but using
car we develop
a set of snt solving modules
and these modules can be combined
to an smt server and this is something
individual
for our server so these are the modules
that we offer currently you see that our
weight is on real algebra this is on the
bottom but we have also some basic
modules and some
non-algebraic decision procedures and we
implemented nearly everything that we
could find
and we can combine these procedures
strategically
by
defining an initial module and then
defining callbacks for it
and that means that this module is
solving the original problem
and for sub problems it can call other
modules
and which module is called might depend
on certain conditions
i'll show you an example traditional smt
solving has a sat module and the theory
module
assume the theory is now the cylindrical
algebraic decomposition for real algebra
so here you see a piece of code how we
can define this strategy
and then we combine the solver with this
code and then you have a static
um statically combined strategy so this
ascent soviet
executes this strategy but the strategy
is still
statically combined but it can be
dynamic depending on the conditions
so for example we can add also the
pre-processing module
we can add bit blasting to eliminate
finite domain
integers or we can call for example the
virtual substitution as an incomplete
method before we go to the heavyweight
cad
or even interval constraint propagation
we can branch on whether the subproblem
is linear or non-linear and this what is
i mean with dynamic so it is also
problem dependent
or we can branch whether the problem is
integer or real
or mixed real integer and then we can
call different backends for those
problems
what is the best tuted
now let me come back to smt solving
so i mentioned that um
assatsova is the
the saturn theory do not have equal
rights the sat server is
kind of uh first in lazy smt survey
and what happens in the sat server
is that if you have a proposition
formula in c and f
then one of the components in the sat
server is resolution
so we have the resolution rule it offers
a complete decision procedure
for propositional logic
it can be used for quantifier
elimination
but why do we have them such servers it
is because
um there is a combinatorial blow up so
in practice
it is not so efficient now how is it
made
more efficient in the 90s is that it is
combined
with exploration so the idea was
that try first go in some direction
apply some cheap look ahead in this case
it is
boolean constraint propagation to direct
the search not to run to every silly
conflict
but if we recognize that he cannot
continue because in that part of the sub
search space there is no solution only
then
we looked the heavy proof system in this
case resolution
to explain why that means to construct
only the part of the proof
which is necessary a little exam to
demonstrate
we have these clauses so first we
propagate
given some atoms must hold we propagate
it and then decide for example
assign force to a did short look at
propagation b cannot imply any
consequences
navi assign false to b and now we see
here because a is force and b is for c
must hold but in the other clause not c
must hold
and only here to this case where we know
there is some conflicting case you apply
boolean conflict resolution
now probably all of you know this so why
do i explain it to you
this is because there was another idea
recently and this is the model
constructing satisfiability calculus
it is not our idea but it is a very
nice idea the idea is now
we give boolean search and theory search
equal rights
they work hand in hand uh being
consistent with the decisions of each
other
but now also the theory should be able
to make decisions
assigning values to variables and
whereas in the boolean case we assign
truth values to propositions in the
theory case
preview effective algebra assign real
values
rear to variables and then we also had a
kind of t propagation theory propagation
and it is not that clearly formulated
but
we can interpret it this way and we also
have conflict resolution in the theory
how does it look like if we do it only
in the theory
assume we have a constraint in one of
the clauses which should be true
according to the boolean structure
now the theory also propagates first
this we can skip it decides let us
look for which values there is a
solution
let us try x equal one
but these guesses are such that
univariate constraints
uh evaluate to their assigned truth
value but now we do not have any
univariate in x so we can choose
whatever we want
then the next variable would be y
we have also no univariate let choose
one try what happens
and now we want to assign a value to z
but now this constraint is univariate
it says that z square is less than zero
and it is not satisfiable so only now
we would involve a theory explanation
procedure that could say for example
that if the constraint holds um
then x and y should not be both positive
because then they cannot satisfy this
constraint or
one of them should be negative
and then these two kinds of search
go in parallel you can combine them as
you want
but they should agree so if the series
if the boolean server says that this
constraint is
true then the theory assignment should
also make it true
okay so this is not new why do i talk
about
it is because um there is something we
can
derive from it a new type of method but
let me explain
this idea on the fourier mod skin
variable elimination because this is
quite easy to
understand and good for illustration so
the idea is if you have
a set of linear constraints no
multiplication
then we can use quantifier elimination
in that we
bring in all constraints the variable to
be eliminated on one hand side
so we get a set of lower bounds green
here and a set of upper bounds
red and then we can
assure that there is a value for x that
satisfies the constraints
if the lower and upper bounds do not
define any empty intervals
that means each of the lower bounds
should be less so equal each of the
upper bounds
this is all and then we can eliminate
every variable that you want
and at the end when we eliminated all
variables
given that there are no parameters we
can decide satisfiability
by checking the resulting constraints of
the constants
so for example if you have these four
constraints we first want to eliminate
x1 so x1 has here two lower bounds and
one upper bound
we combine each with each so we get two
constraints
and the one without having x1 we just
keep
we go on eliminate also x2
so here we have again two lower bounds
and one upper bound
we combine each with each and then we
recognize
there is a conflict because one cannot
be less to equal zero so this set of
constraints
is unsatisfiable
now if we use fourier muscle
mcdot to explain conflicts
how does it look like so this method is
uh also complete
but it is also like resolution
combinatorially heavy
so let us try to do something else and
um
use fourier moskin and snt solving to
explain a conflict so what happens
we have here assume these four
constraints should be true
and now we try to guess
in the theory domain values
so first we want to guess the value for
x2
this constraint is not yet only there
yet and this one neither
so our look ahead goes only for
satisfying univariates
but this constraint is only variant and
it should be true according to the
boolean assignment
so we can choose any value that is
at at most zero letters to zero it is a
nice number a lot of things
can zero out and these are the
constraints if i substitute 0 for x2
okay let us continue we want to guess
also value for x1
and now we have here 3 univariate
constraints in
x1 and we see we have a problem because
x1 should be larger equal to but less to
equal zero this cannot be satisfied
and now we have the two constraints
which stay in conflict for this
assignment and we can use footy about
skin to derive
a new statement namely
if both constraint hold then x should
have the value at least one
now we can learn this close
and then backtrack because the choice
for um
x2 was wrong for the given um x
um x1 cannot be chosen so the undo
decision for x2 and choose another one
that satisfies not this constraint
and the problem here is that you learn
constraints and you lift this up into
the boolean level that means
you need propagation again to to direct
the search away and
perhaps we could turn around and put
this idea another way
so we thought cannot be instead of
putting folio mosquito into mczart
cannot we put a kind of mcd into fourier
mod skin
so let us guide the fourier mod skin
elimination procedure
by exploration so let us do the same
we start and guess a value for x2 we
have one bound it should be less so
equal zero so let us get zero
now we try to get the value for x1
and we see well here we have a lower
bound zero
we have here a lower bound two and here
an upper bound zero
so these two are in conflict for this
value i cannot
extend it to the next dimension so let
us explain it why
we apply one foreign mosque in step
to get this constraint and we see that
our current
simplified it means that x2 should be at
least one
and now because our current assignment
does not satisfy it we backtrack
and choose a new value okay perhaps
we try to choose one but we see that it
should be at least one at most zero
which is not possible so again we
explain this
by applying to these two conflicting uh
statements one
step from foreign and we are done with
the proof
so we even recognize that this
constraint is not relevant
so we do not need to apply it
so this is the idea but we do not want
to do it for free mod skin
because linear arithmetic is quite
efficient with the existing method we
want it to do
for non-linear real algebra and in order
to explain that
just shortly uh i need to give a little
bit
background to the cylindrical algebraic
decomposition which i assume that you
not all know
i will not go into very much details but
let us first start with the univariate
case so we have an univariate polynomial
and we would like to know whether it has
a certain sign condition
so for example whether it can get
negative
and the key while real algebra is
decidable or at least for the univariate
case
uh the the reason is that each
polynomial has
finitely many real zeros at most the
degree of the polynomial
and if we can compute these zeros
if we could compute it actually we
cannot compute it we can isolate them so
but we can compute with them
symbolically
and so this is possible and then we know
that between two zeros a sign of the
polynomial is invariant
okay because it is a continuous function
so
between two zeros it cannot get from
positive to negative or the other way
so if we can compute the zeros we do not
need to know how the function
looks like we take the zeros and samples
between them and left and right
and then we just substitute all of these
into the polynomial and check that the
sign
and then we can answer this question if
one of the sample fits
the problem is satisfiable otherwise
it's unsatisfiable
and this idea can be extended also to
the
multivariate case but there it is all of
course a bit more complicated because
polynomials have none or finitely many
zeros but
continuous varieties
uh which you can see here for these two
constraints two polynomials the blue one
has
uh the variety here and the green one is
this line
so if you want to check now the
satisfiability of this we also need
something like sine invariant regions
and the cylindrical algebraic
decomposition
defines by certain procedure
with which i do not want to explain here
defines so-called cylinders
which are stacks of sine invariant
regions
its text i mean for example look at here
in the middle
we have here a sine invariant region
over the whole width of the cell
of the cylinder and then on top of it we
have here one sine invariant region
cuts through the whole cell the whole
cylinder
then here we have next one here we have
a next one
and why it is nice is that now i can
guess any x
x value here within this interval
and either i can extend it to a sign
satisfying
point or none of these x values can be
extended
so i can guess any values
incrementally dimension by dimension and
then if i test all of them then i can
check the satisfiability of this formula
this is a very nice method but its
disadvantages of course it is
complexity doubly exponentially inverse
case
so it's heavy and
there was a very very nice idea for for
the motor constructed satisfied with the
calculus actually was designed
for cid as an explanation mechanism
behind it
let me give you an intuition how it
works the same as fourier modscan but
now
we guess values for real
valued variables and evaluate them over
polynomials which is a bit more complex
because
we need to be able to guess real
algebraic numbers
but let us not go into the detail but
only the
idea so for example we get 0.5 for x
this is here
we could choose it freely because there
is no univariate constraint in x
now let us plug in x equals 0.5 to the
problem and we get this one
now we have only variate constraints in
y and we see that this one is not
possible again for a similar reason than
before
because this is a square and a positive
number cannot
give a negative sum and now we need to
explain it
and the idea is to generate a cad
from this polynomial so from the only
from the conflicting constraints
we take the polynomials and generate the
cd but not the full cd just the cell
and in this case because it is not
possible
the reason is this uh quadratic
polynomial and we get as an
explanation that none of the values here
for
x should be taken
and how to explain this because now we
need to argue about zeros of polynomials
this is done in the way
if the constraint c1 was this is the
blue one
then x should not be less than the first
zero of this polynomial this is the
discriminant of this polynomial
which um the first zero of them is that
this point defining
the x value where this turnaround
happens
so that the solution set pops up
okay so you see already one problem we
need to
be able to compute with the zero
expressions for polynomials
of this representation for zeros of
polynomials and then we continue so for
example we get now
we have here an univariate problem in x
so we choose a
value which satisfies this constraint
for example we can choose
this value 1.2 and now we evaluate the
polynomial at this point we get new
constraints
and we try to search for a value for y
and it is also not possible but
now we need both constraints
and again navi construct the cad
for these two polynomials but not the
whole city just one cell description
and this describes us actually
this area in x can be excluded
and then if you continue uh you see that
now the expression learned get
more complex and then first once we have
luck we guess x
equals two and if we substitute we can
extend it to a solution
okay and now what i explained for the
furious
method the question was that um we asked
ourselves
well if you can put cad or not much to
cad
like said construction a cad cell
is constructed as explanation if this is
helpful
would it be also helpful to put kind of
mc that exploration
into the cid because how does this mc
that
search looks like well it get is some
value
and then it excludes certain areas
by explanations from higher dimensional
spaces
and then once for this x value there is
no
other possibility to choose another one
and so on it will try to cover the whole
state space with
exclusions until there is no possibility
left and we know that the problem is
unsatisfiable or it finds a solution
somewhere
and the problem is that if we
want to put explanation into this cad
it constructs cylindrically so we do not
learn there in the sense that we learn
new clauses and propagate in them this
mechanism
is not in cad so somehow in order to
make this method useful for the cid we
need
still a kind of cylindrical structure
for the search it doesn't work otherwise
and the idea is well just make it
cylindrical so what we do is
we also guess and if the guess is wrong
then we generate
explanations as before but once one
dimension is completed i have no father
choice everything is excluded
then we take the cylindrical
intersections of them
so in this case you see within this area
it is fully covered another magic is to
adapt the projection operators
of the cad such that we can compute
this cylinder as large as possible using
as
few projections as possible
and then when we are done then we
go into the search tree at other places
we also guess
and by the continuation we exclude
pieces
and then if we excluded the hole so the
gas cannot be extended
everything in the next dimension is
covered by explanations
then again to fit a cylindrical
structure around it
exclude it and then continue
also here vivia cover
and continue cylindrical extensions and
now you see
what we get is not a cylindrical
algebraic decomposition anymore
but it is a cylindrical algebraic
covering because the cylinders might
overlap
okay is it good in practice here you see
some results
what you see here is the traditional
smt with cads series solver
in the next one you see a modification
with the cad
statical structure first project
dimension visor everything and then lift
up for those who know
who they see how the seed is working it
is modified
that we can make a partial projection
can try precious samples
such that we can detect satisfiability
without doing the whole work
the third one is the covering
and the last one is the mcsat with c80
it is called an
asset and you see that the covering
is good but it is not better that
analyzer
but this covering
does not yet have this incrementality
included
it has still the static projection
structure so if we improve this
and add this incrementality then we have
the shown still to beat the
currently best approach mcd
for nonlinear arithmetic and one more
interesting point
is if you compute here the running times
for the benchmarks that we took
from the snt benchmark set
you see that the difference is
not really big so here a lot of things
that both can solve relatively fast
and here's some divergence but here you
see a lot of
uh benchmarks that analyst
can solve is hard for the covering
but also a lot of benchmarks that the
covering can solve
a heart for any asset so this would be
interesting
uh to look at whether that is really
only heuristical because these are
really a lot so here you have something
like 300 benchmarks and you have
something like
500 benchmarks so this is not
does not seem to be um accident
but we cannot explain it yet
okay so i hope that
uh my talk could you give you a little
bit of
impression what mcg does and how we can
turn it around
to put this exploration idea to compute
some decisions procedures with
exploration
so guide the search by exploration
and how it nicely can extend existing
methods
and improve them and actually this is
also very good related to the skirt is
made because he also tries to explore um
in the sad case and then basically the
cast gives
these explanations but there
it is not the boolean abstraction and
the other cases but the division is
different
but i see parallelized in both of them
so thank you for your attention and if
you have any questions then i'm happy to
answer
thank you for a great talk erica
fantastic talk questions please
erica i had a couple of questions um you
mentioned
uh that you know
your integration is essentially
in some way similar to the mcsat
the way you integrated cad into into the
smt solver was through this mcsat
approach right and it was
integral to how uh
your technique works correct is that
fair yes so there are two different
approaches one the
nlsrt this is the mc that with cid
it was called analysis by the authors
and this um guesses at the boolean level
and that the theory level
and learns explanations right it says
if the following constraints hold
together then exclude this cad
cell and what we propose is
it is a pure theory solver for
conjunctions of constraints
and we use this guidance to look
first and only if we have conflicts
then we apply
the generation of cad cells
but now we keep the cylindrical
structure in the search
and this allows us not to learn because
we always
at the same cylinder we look at the
future and the higher dimensions
and if we exclude them deeply backtrack
so we do not
learn therefore all this propagation
falls away and um yeah
so the difference is that the cells that
are generated by mcsat to cover the
state space
to exclude all uh real
values in the domain are not structured
therefore they can also be reused but
they must be learned
and in all these learned constraints you
need to propagate
and therefore um it might be
expensive and also for each cell
generation you not need to start the
the whole projection and so on from a
new
so the idea was let us keep the cid
structure
so we do a similar thing than the
original cid does
so it is really only a theory solver in
traditional smt
solving but inside of the cad
we apply exploration
not to consider always all polynomials
but only those which
matter because we explore nvc
for this partial sample certain sign
conditions cannot be
satisfied together and then the computer
cell
only in the cfd of those constraints
which matter
and this is the big big
speed up that we gain but thereby we
lose the
decomposition but we get a covering
so in in other ways you you actually
flip
the search versus theory exactly we fit
this so
basically in mcdot you have um
the boolean and the theory
guess first and then you derive
something learn it
and you need the boolean level to
propagate
to lead away from these in the future
we do not learn do not propagate
but need the cylindrical structure to to
to remember what we excluded
already and what uh we need to check in
the future
it is because it is mathematically quite
a bit involved it is not easy to explain
it
easily but this is what you say is
exactly the point so
flip it um yeah
i had one more question so i i
i think mcsat was approached as a as a
distinct
architecture for smt solvers
but to the extent that i know other than
an lsat nobody has kind of quite picked
it up
um well um yeah actually nsf was
introduced first and then generalized to
mcsat
true yeah i think it was picked up
for floating point something floating
point arithmetic computations i think
but i am not so much aware but i think
that it is
could be promising also to other
theories
if you can generate generalizations
these are the explanations if you find
something unsatisfiable to generalize it
to an element from a finite domain such
that you can also assure termination
right more questions please
uh if not let's thank erica again for a
wonderful talk thank you erica
thank you thank you thank you
uh next is emery
yorko i am rick would you